hey what's up guys my name is Hoshino
and welcome to episode 105 of game
programming so today we're gonna talk
about random targeting so we have a
shooter mob right now if we launch a
game just so you guys can see what is
that you can see that if I move over
here these mobs right there's two of the
shooters there's this top one here in
the bottom one
they both target the closest mob that's
to them so if I move over here for
example you can see they're gonna target
me and then if I move out of range you
can say this one here is actually
targeting the one that's just to its
left not me because the left one is
obviously closer and then you can see
that the accuracy is a pinpoint here now
that's great but what if we want them to
target a random mob that's in the the
area right so the reason that I did I
even want to consider this is because in
realm of the mad God which is kind of a
game that we're sort of cloning here not
really though because we're gonna add a
ton of stuff that's not in that game
that game you know that has random
targeting right so it's not just gonna
target the closest player some more some
monsters might do that right I explained
this last episode of thing some on the
last few episodes at least some mobs are
gonna target the the closest player
right but some might not some might
target a random player okay and then it
might change that every now and then so
how do we actually get it to target
something random well what we've got
right now is what I call like a closest
kind of algorithm right this this finds
the closest one and what I'm gonna do is
I'm actually gonna move this entire
thing right with shoot I'm gonna grab
that I'm gonna cut that and I'm actually
gonna make a private method here private
void shoot closest all right and I'm
gonna paste that entire thing into there
okay and the reason that I've done that
let me just get rid of that so you guys
can see a bit more the reason that I've
done that is um in fact if you
double-click on any tab here you can see
if it like the shooter Java class tab if
I double click on that it's actually
gonna like maximizer to make it
fullscreen so that that's the pro tip
for you guys if you didn't know that so
this shoot closes right that's going to
shoot the closest engine and that's what
that's all it's gonna do right so if you
want to run that you simply type in
closest and that's what will be done
right so if I launch a now of course
it's gonna um it's gonna work as it did
before
now let's uh let's not run that method
let's instead go shoot random okay and
we're gonna make that method now it's a
private void shoot random this is
largely going to be very very similar to
to this shoot closest method in fact I'm
just gonna copy and paste this entire
thing into here and then we're gonna
edit it okay so first of all yeah we do
need this entities with the client
player
we need all that stuff there minimum
distance you know we don't need that
closest we might not really need that on
my call this R and we can call it random
because random is our random object and
it's our instance of the random Java
cloth we don't need this since we don't
need this stuff but we do need this for
loop and this if closest will go random
does not equal null mmm we don't need
this closest stuff all we do need though
is rent or get ex and all that stuff
okay that's it so what we're gonna edit
here is this thing this is dead code
comp linkers we never actually sat
around and we call do anything so don't
worry about this warning that'll go away
once we actually make R and equal to a
random entity so what we're gonna do
right first of all when we're shooting a
random thing it's gonna be very very
simple okay we've got an array list of
entries in fact we don't even need this
for loop okay we've got an ArrayList of
entities we can access any of them we're
going entities get so what we're
actually gonna do right is we're going
to create our random index and what
that's gonna equal is entities dot size
minus one all right
that's gonna kind of be if I just get
rid of in fact we can move this down and
I will I'll explain this just in a
second so I'm done up now okay so
basically our index is the index in the
entities array at which we pull an
entity okay because its entities array
is obviously full of entities right here
it is where we get it from the level get
entities class and the idea is that we
want to randomly pick an entity
out of there okay right now of course by
the way I just know that a lot of you
guys are thinking well isn't that gonna
pull old all the older entities in the
level I don't want to shoot at someone
who's not on the other side of the map
of course it won't because level don't
get entities has a radius parameter
which is 500 at this point so don't
worry about that it will pick a random
entity within this radius so we can
tweak this radius to be 20 which is just
pretty much really really close distance
so that's like kind of sword um Malay
distance not really I don't projected
distance and then you can make it really
really large like 10,000 and that will
obviously obviously I'm shoot pretty
much everything in in our level at least
cuz it's small but that's the idea right
so you can tweak this radius to be you
know I guess the range pretty much now
this is the index right so what we want
to do now is kind of let us pick a
random number between 0 and that okay
because entities that size will give us
the number of entities in our entities
ArrayList okay that's the number of
entities we go minus 1 because arrays
start from 0 at least the indexes start
from 0 okay so not from 1 so this gives
us the the count but we want to make
sure that of course if we have 10
entities the last one is actually number
9 because the first one is not 1 it's 0
so what we need to do then is go ahead
and say random dot whoops random yep
next int and then we're actually gonna
make it make the parameter this entities
dot size and the way that this is going
to work very very simply is because
random dot next int right this is the
maximum value that that actual integer
will be okay so in X n n is is the it's
the it's some this probably won't help
you guys out and immensely basically
it's that it's the top okay so if this
were to be eight this would actually
pick a number between one and eight oh
sorry zero and I think it might be
actually zero so we'll see let's go
ahead and check
souther energy cell size - one that will
pick a random integer between zero and
that value
so once we've done that right we simply
have to get get the random entity and
that all simply be entities get and then
index okay because index is that random
index that we pick out there are many
other ways of doing this by the way but
this is one of the ways because there
are show you guys one more way in a
second but that'll be a random way now
one thing I'm gonna note I'm gonna I'm
just gonna let you guys know before we
actually launch our application this
will actually um do it every frame right
there's no kind of limiting factor here
so it will it will pick a random person
to shoot do it every update okay so I'm
we're gonna see what this looks like
right now look at that it looks like
they're shooting at everyone so um
because it's kind of working right
because it's um they're all kind of
firing it this guy I don't even know
what's going on here it's just it's
crazy they're all firing at random
random positions and they're all
changing it so let's go ahead and tweak
this just a bit because this probably
isn't the desired result results so what
we want to do is make some kind of there
is a time okay we've actually made that
already which is which is nice but what
I want to do is I only want to change
the I guess the index that we shoot out
every now and then so what we need to do
is grab in the entity R and we want to
copy that
put it up here so that it stays of
course in between we'll set it equal to
null to begin with which is the default
anyway but just so we enforce that and
then all I want to do is you see this R
and equals the basically this entire
thing I only want to do this right if
either Rand actually you know what if we
don't need to do with Rand doesn't equal
null all right if Rand equals null
because if it equals knowledge
astronomers here anyway so if time mod
where's my mod mod like 60 maybe once
per second equals zero and we're gonna
do this entire little feel here okay
otherwise you know what it's not gonna
change our rand ever okay
let's go ahead and check that out and
see what's going on here okay so you can
see that this guy here is kind of
changing who is shooting out so one time
is shooting at this guy and other time
he's shooting at this guy and we get
that entire kind of notion going on see
he's changing um he's just randomly
changing it once per second okay and
that's what's going on here
now the other thing that's probably on
your guy's mind is why is the plane ever
getting picked yeah we can always say
that this is going on but the player
just never kind of would never get to
never get shot up and that's because um
this random am excellent method as I
mentioned earlier it doesn't actually
count up to the top value that's like
the it's kind it works kind of like an
array right so if we actually put in
eight we will get a random number from
zero to seven inclusive okay so what
that is is the range right that is eight
total numbers starting from zero okay
zero one two three four five six and
seven that's eight values so because of
that we don't actually go ahead and say
entities yet sorry and do so size minus
one we actually don't need the minus one
there
okay I just wanted you guys to to see
that because um normally you would do
that though that's why that's why I
wanted to point it out it's just that
this next int method just kind of does
that for you okay which honestly I don't
think it should do but it does because
that's just the way that the job of
people have written it but keep in mind
that if you're doing a for loop or
whatever and you don't want the that's
why though that's why it's really
important just just really quickly
that's why it's really important to note
that you know how you go when you make a
full loop you go ahead and you say I is
less than and then like actually still
size and that works fine that's because
I never actually equals this okay as
always because as soon as I is it this
only works if eyes less than that right
so if I is less than equal to
that right that's how that's how it
works okay so basically what you need to
realize is in like a follow up of course
I never actually reaches this value it
doesn't because if it were to equal it
suddenly then that wouldn't be less than
right that the bullying expression of
less than would not be true and it
wouldn't run so that's just something
that's really important to know so now
that we do go and it is the size and the
reason that the player is always the
last index is because first we pull the
entities and then we obviously add add
the player onto the end of the entities
ArrayList so let's check that out
another player should get picked every
now and then you can see I think that's
that's us he's shooting out yep and you
can see that they kind of did it
randomly change all that stuff now one
more quick thing is I think yes I'm good
I'm just gonna say that um if you guys
wanted to model or something as in like
change the model not actually like
modify it but change the modulus some
thing you could just simply add a random
done next and like 60 for example and it
would go ahead and say okay it will
start at zero this would be 59 actually
so that's another thing to know if you
actually wanted to be between 0 0 and 60
you'd have to add 61 that's actually one
of the reasons I don't like the next
method very much but um what I'm saying
is that basically anywhere from let's
just say one second to two seconds
anywhere in that range it will actually
what did I put the second bracket that's
one anywhere between 1 and 1 to 2
seconds it will change direction right
so you can kind of tweak that a bit
maybe even bring this to 30 this to 90
and then that will basically make sure
that anyway between half a second and 2
seconds you'll actually get a direction
switching and that'll be a bit more
realistic a half second might be not
enough it might be a bit really abrupt
so we'll wait for this guy to shoot us
there we go so you can see it's kind of
cool right in the sense that he can kind
of change the direction really really
quickly and he can like fire just a few
shots at us and then go back to someone
else right so that's random targeting
all right I did tell you that I would
show you one more way to shoot randomly
and that is you don't need this stuff
anymore I'll quickly show you guys this
we're probably not going to use this
technique just because I think it's
probably gonna be a bit slower and it
actually messes up a bunch of stuff but
what
we could do is is do it this way instead
if I just copy this really quickly as
well we can just say that if if entities
dot size we have to move this out here
so we don't need the time stuff yet but
if entities dot size is greater than
zero so in other words if the entities
are raised and empty because of course
it can be if we're if our mob is out
somewhere in like the wilderness and
there aren't any mobs around it in that
radius then yeah and that there's like
then this list will be empty but if it's
not empty we'll go ahead and shoot and
the person will shoot at will actually
be our random entity kind of will
actually be equal to brought that with
me Rand will actually be equal to and
she's get zero okay so that'll always
get the first entity but you guys might
be like well okay isn't the first entity
always gonna be the same and yet we'll
be but what we run before that which
will up here actually is we actually run
collections static method collections
dot shuffle and then we fade in the
entities list alright that will shuffle
it into random or if I just go ahead and
do this thing really quickly you can see
that um they'll actually they'll
actually you can see they're actually
only firing one shot at us every now and
then but um it will actually it'll
shuffle it and it'll fire randomly okay
and you can see a few shots are fired at
this guy as well
they are preferring each other a lot but
that's just the way that that works
alright because and the reason that's
happening is because we're only
shuffling every now and then so what we
need to do is kind of we'd have to tweak
odd a lot of a lot of stuff to get that
to work but basically if we were to
bring this outside it would be um
shuffling in every frame and you can see
that that is truly random okay anyway
we're not gonna do this way just because
that does actually change they'll change
the well I I guess it just kind of
changes the order of our entire
collection and we might want to keep it
in a particular water so I'm just gonna
reset that quickly to what it was but
that's just you know just for your guys
I guess some
information just another way of doing it
so that collections does shuffle is
quite quite good alright so and she's
out sighs I think everything's right
then which news had R and we're sat
around equal to UM entities dog gets
index and that is I think that's it
that should work now who are you
shooting at okay
almost what did I forget something this
should be outside I think that's the
only thing I forgot all right I guess
that's pretty much how that random
method will work so I hope you guys
enjoyed this episode of game programming
next time we're gonna take a look at
creating eight debug kind of display
purely for being able to draw or um
actually draw debug information I'll
just text onto the screen because we're
gonna need that in the future and then
hopefully we'll move on to some more
interesting stuff but that debug stuff
is really really important and I can't
wait to get that down because it will
help us out with pretty much all future
development
so anyway anyway if you guys enjoyed
this episode please hit the like button
don't forget that I actually offer a
private tutoring little thing going on
so if you guys want to learn java or you
want to learn this if there's anything
that you guys basically want to learn in
the realm of either this tutorial or and
anything to do with java or c++ if you
guys are just starting out in those
languages and and you need some guidance
and you want to you want to learn how to
um how to do that basically then feel
free to out to book a tutorial here my
available times well list in this
calendar basically you just have to fill
out this form pick the time here and
pick how long you want that toward the
toriel to go for so 15 30 or 60 minutes
and that's pretty much it and just type
in what you want to learn here and and
out of out of the people who have taken
this by the way so far there's been like
a hundred percent
so everyone who's everyone everyone
who's had a tutorial like basically
wants another one so they've been really
successful and and it's really awesome
that I can actually help people out face
to face so I hope you guys enjoyed this
and I'll see you guys hopefully tomorrow
with another episode goodbye
you